from lockdowns to reopenings from no
crowds to tons of people
transitioning back isn't always that
easy yeah we all know a lot of kids have
had a hard time with the past
year but what's happening now is a
concern as well
orc old man alive in studio joining us
now with ways to help out orco
well brian and denise change is hard and
that's especially true for our kids
so mental health nonprofits are making
it clear to young people in need
as well as their parents that there is
help available
i want to learn because i like school
eight-year-old nico mariano has
struggled with distance education during
the pandemic and like many across the
valley it's impacted his mental health
but what's happening now as he returns
to the classroom is also presenting some
problems
really dizzy it's like going over around
a circle
big changes can be a roller coaster ride
for kids but nico hopes counseling
through the non-profit united citizens
foundation can make a difference
i come to me to be
brave and breathe or
concentrate nico's mom wants to see that
too
the earlier on that you learn i feel
like that will set him up for success in
the future
councilor crystal acosta works with
about 30 kids every week she says while
resuming in-person learning and seeing
vegas come alive again is exciting for
some kids
it can also cause anxiety for others
it's like what's it going to be like
plus all these covert roles with like
you know social distancing wearing a
mask like
it's not normal but teaching kids deep
breathing and muscle relaxation
exercises can help
we do skills that they can you know feel
better and lower their anxiety
while in the situation nico is ready to
learn and he's encouraging others in
need to do the same
everyone has their fears and my families
and
friends must face the fears
now united citizens foundation received
some grant funding during the pandemic
so they can cover the cost for those who
are uninsured there are also
other great resources for kids in need
we have details on our website
8newsnow.com